[Music]
so
[Music]
this is a business card i made for a
company when i was 14 years old that i
actually registered
and called it
rancid pie productions i have no idea
why i called it that but it led to 18
years of me doing what i love every
single day and scaling it into a one
million dollar global business with
incredible people i would consider
family
in this video i'm going to show you how
i with three simple steps turned a
childhood fantasy into a million dollar
business
hey i'm dan mace i've carried this book
around with me for the past 10 years
it's filled with the most challenging
ideas i've ever had and this show is
dedicated to getting them done
welcome to the brew show
[Music]
this is the final episode of the brew
show the final unfinished idea in my
ideabook which i wrote five years ago
find a way to constantly make rad
[ __ ] videos for the rest of your life
it's important to note that i never went
to business school and my intent has
never been to make lots of money so
after many failures a [ __ ] ton of work
and a lot of luck i'm going to pass on
my secret to building a successful
business from tiny one-man bands to
larger scale businesses this isn't a
how-to guide rather it's a how i did its
story and three simple steps with the
hope that you can extract something from
it step one purpose
what makes you get up in the morning
without going
[ __ ] let's talk about purpose i'll
define purpose as a combination of a
calling of sorts something you're
naturally good at something you have a
knack for combined with the undeniable
burning desire to keep doing this thing
till you get good enough at it to get
paid to keep doing it and then the cycle
continues hopefully forever for me that
was obviously making films after
starring in a mcdonald's art as a kid i
made enough money to purchase my very
first camera and when i looked through
the viewfinder i just knew this is it
i'll do anything to keep doing this for
the rest of my life so that's what i did
i started a production company at the
age of 14 that made just enough to give
me pocket money and fund my little
passion project looking back my purpose
hasn't changed in 18 years i'm still
doing the same thing i was back then but
now just on a larger scale
maybe you haven't found your purpose yet
and that's totally fine like anna marie
moses who began painting at the age of
77 as a hobby where she originally
charged three to five dollars for her
original pieces but prices quickly
skyrocketed to ten thousand dollars and
when she died at the age of 101 years
old one of her paintings ended up
selling for 3.6 million us dollars don't
ever compare yourself to anyone else you
are living in your time zone your
purpose will come like for me i always
thought i was the dumb kid at school
because i didn't care about the stuff i
was being taught and therefore would get
terrible marks yet i would study films i
would watch every single director's
round table discussion i read books on
the art of composition and i did this
because it was something that i was
actually interested in learning and
still do it today
then luck starts to present itself i
simply understand luck as your past
selves opportunities that you rarely
took on awarding your present self this
whole mantra of do what you love and
you'll never work a day in your life is
[ __ ]
talent and passion only get you so far
so you're gonna have to work really
[ __ ] hard and sometimes it's gonna
hurt but this ultimately leads to a lot
of luck my lucky break came when i made
a film for fun with a few friends that
got entered into cannes with a few of my
other films and i ended up winning three
khan awards i then got signed as a
director at a production house at the
age of 24 however i very quickly started
to feel like an impostor i was the
youngest director there by around 15
years i just didn't have the experience
and i constantly told myself that i
wasn't good enough and this lasted for
about two years it was around this time
that casey neistat recognized my work
yeah and offered me a position to move
to new york and help him start a brand
called 368 which basically meant filming
his daily vlogs and attempting to edit
them constantly they're getting tired
yet dan
no
i'm good
as well as being a character of sorts in
the vlog i took on this opportunity not
only because i needed the life
experience but because i mean to have
casey neistat as a mentor is priceless
this was honest to god the hardest i've
ever worked in my entire life i would
come back to my apartment sometimes at
night and cry not knowing where this
decision was going to take me but i kept
telling myself if i just stuck to it
casey would recognize my drive and
eventually give me a platform which he
did he launched my youtube career by
making a video on his channel dedicated
to asking people to go over and
subscribe to my channel and this grew my
channel by hundreds of thousands of
people which is just nuts
i then started creating my own content
for my own youtube channel and slowly
built a community of like-minded people
from all around the world which is now
known as the brew community
i later moved back to south africa to
get married and like any business opened
up my very first office in a garage soon
after i realized with the kinds of films
i wanted to make that i could not do it
alone which leads me to the next step
when you realize that you're in a
financial position through a pipeline of
constant work you are going to need step
two people i hired my first ever
employee through sending out an
instagram post looking for an assistant
luke has now grown from being an
assistant editor to now a full-time
director for big companies like the
discovery channel luke and i then grew
to three people then four and then five
in less than a year and this was solely
from youtube work we then needed a
bigger space when i decided that i
wanted to slow down on youtube being the
main source of income and rather expand
into a production company so that i
could start directing again i got this
space which i turned into my dream
studio and started a production house an
agency called joe which is named after
my beautiful sausage dog that passed i
started hiring young talented people and
mentoring them like casey did for me and
in less than a year we grew to 13
full-time staff members from editors
musicians directors a finance team
producers and brand strategists and we
are constantly growing we will also be
opening an alley branch soon side note
i'm still going to be youtubing but not
as much and more about all the exciting
[ __ ] we get to do the way i explained
growing a team sounded super easy but it
is so difficult finding the right people
and even tougher to manage them no one
can train you for that so what i did was
look at everything i despised about the
traditional model of film production how
i was treated as a film director and
taken advantage of so with joe i decided
to put people first to build a company
culture where we can lean on one another
in moments of doubt we are open about
things like mental health and invite
vulnerability into our discussions it
was a super expensive risk in the
beginning taking on full-time staff and
paying these super outrageous overheads
but it has paid off from 2019 we have
doubled our profits every year and will
keep doing so i invest in people not
things and i can honestly say sitting
here i love every single team member at
joe
step three profit
if you nail the first two steps profit
is inevitable profit is described as
financial gain but to me profit is also
being able to serve your purpose to do
what you love every single day with
incredible people and as a bonus getting
paid to do so
we to date as joe have completed over 20
jobs for warner brothers discovery made
countless ads short films and worked
with incredible brands on multiple
youtube videos and we don't even have a
website but i'm actually thinking now
while saying this i'm going to create a
website before this video goes live so
you'll see it in the link below go check
it out if you'd like to join us be a
part of the team or hire us to make rad
meaningful [ __ ] for you or for your
brand as i said before i'll be keeping
you up to date on my youtube channel
monthly with what we're up to like
shooting my first ever feature film this
is just the beginning for us thank you
so much for watching and i hope that you
could have learned something from this
video other than that don't forget
you're awesome brew and it's sad to say
goodbye to the brew show for now but
i'll see you soon on my youtube channel
so
[Music]